come here come here
oh there's evidence a heaven Evan are
you gonna go to school today
you can't look at it okay Evan can you
say bye bye bye say bye bye everyone bye
bye okay I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
seven
okay okay that's that's s107
favorite vacation that's nila Disneyland
what do you like at Disneyland
I can't free right what do you like
doing there what do you like to do it
Disney what do you like to see Mickey
cloud loves Harry many Disney honking
tell friends Inca I'm goo here are you
like Playhouse Disney a playhouse
how do you spell wonderful look at the
camera very good
how about ask for help what did you have
for breakfast Devin I green you didn't
have ice cream for breakfast what did
you have for breakfast what yeah yeah W
it starts with a w what yeah woof very
good that is wof a what did you have a
waffle oh yeah yes
my mic on so you'd use putting your
puzzle together Wow
what is the puzzle of yeah who's on the
puzzle and then listen to Ethan he's
giving you a cleaner that's exactly what
you tell him
okay wipe you're not as house good job
wipe your nose like this I've been
listened to Ethan eat I'm in a right fit
what are you doing Eman what are we
doing Evan everybody making what are you
making you're making soup and what are
we doing with these vegetables that's
yours Evan
this is my painting shadows look pretty
how to get a ranch yeah well we're into
the ranch what are we gonna do with them
in the fridge are we gonna cook them
babies - oh yeah oh my gosh beneath - oh
my gosh that's gonna be fun we got a
right number two
[Music]
[Applause]
I like the ability to be generated but
my teachers to teach today healthy happy
in basketball a color movie it makes
please my god
healthy is my color comparison Beecham
oh I like the green grass right there I
love the fresh air I like my great towel
but I love my beautiful backpack I our
lives a sunny day but I love the
crashing waves I like to pull the rest
but I love my Eagles
[Applause]
you